what up space fam golson here from anime
outpouring today i have a very hyped
topic for you discussing the real reason
why all demons and even non-demons fear
tundra kamado the kind-hearted
protagonist of demon slayer so make sure
to stay tuned for that if you do enjoy
seeing these demon stare videos i want
to keep them coming you know what to do
channel the demonstrator within and
smash that like button with no mercy
remember smashing that like button is
demonstrated energy and passing is moves
on energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates and
while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing demonstrator playlist that
includes videos called the hashira all
the demon moons and much more videos
like this one so link to that is in the
description and now without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and all so
in the latest episode of demons here we
had a few moments which made me want to
cover this topic before any other what
is so special about tundra protagonist
and for that matter is there something
special we've known for a while that
tanjiro's got the special earrings that
freak moves on out and kyojo and goku's
father also pretty much said he's one of
the chosen few who has the strongest
breath style sun breathing he mentions
tundra's earrings as being the sign of a
sun breather when they first meet on not
so nice terms right away tundra guesses
right when it crosses his mind that sun
breathing could mean hinokami kagura at
this point we again see the figure of
the first and strongest breath style
user whose name is yorichi but more on
that later now let's fast forward to
where we are in the anime right now as
tanjo is fighting doki he remembers
reading shinjuru's letter where he
apologized for his behavior and he
explains again that tundra has a greater
power than kyojira did which is hype
since kyojiro was one of the strongest
hashira shindra wrote and i quote like
you those destined to wield sun
breathing are born with a red mark on
their foreheads and as we know now
tundra has a mark on his forehead that
is similar to the one yurichi the first
and strongest breath style user had now
i'm not sure why the mangaka did this
but then tundra goes on to explain that
he wasn't actually born with the mark
first he got hurt by protecting his
brother and then it evolved so to speak
when he was wounded during final
selection so yeah he wasn't born with it
but he is wearing the earrings he does
have the mark and he is the only known
wielder of sun breathing it's like
avatar the last sun breather so even
though tundra says he doesn't have the
powers of a chosen one it's pretty clear
he is the chosen one for this series
even if admittedly he can't do it all on
his own and he does need help on the way
to carrying out his destiny while tundra
fights and lectures daki about the
importance of human life she gets
flashes of yurichi with his demonstrator
mark and the same earrings doki realizes
it is not her memories but memories from
musan's blood this man traumatized muzan
so bad that all demons he's created
which is virtually all demons share this
fear of him on a cellular level and
tundra is the one that reminds them of
him tundra is presented as a kind of
modern day successor to yurichi tundra
goes on to use sun breathing to almost
take out daki by himself very impressive
even if she's not a full upper moon
without her brother however at this
point in time he's just not there yet he
hasn't honed his body and mind to the
point where he can use sun breathing to
its fullest and so he has to stop
mid-attack when his sister's spirit
reminds him to breathe still you know
for a second there doki was very scared
thinking about how she's about to get
wrecked and that's even without the
whole ptsd in muzon's blood thing so to
fully understand this all demons are
scared of tundra thing we gotta turn to
this yurichi guy for a minute during
chapter 186 of the manga we get
yurichi's backstory we find out that
yorichi knew and saved tundra's ancestor
sumiyoshi we find out that as we know
yorichi wore the same earrings but
furthermore we find out that they were a
gift from his mom who prayed to the sun
deity to shine warmly on yurichi seems
very fitting he had a tragic backstory
which is a topic for another video but
he ended up becoming a demonstrator and
taught others to use breathing styles
eventually he ran into muzon the
progenitor of demons and he knew he was
born to kill this man this is the fight
that traumatized musan yorichi wrecked
him like tanjiro yorichi's sword was
originally black but turned bright red
during battle this shows that from the
beginning tundra was meant to be a sun
breather too and he eventually learns to
turn his blade bright red as well first
with nezuko's help and then without it
during the muzon yurichi battle we're
told that the bright red blade worked
well against muzon preventing him from
regenerating properly we'll see how the
anime does it but in the manga it looks
like muzon takes one shot yurichi dodges
it and then slashes apart muzon's body
in a split second it wasn't a one piece
epic fight that lasts for 5 days this
was a few seconds if that immediately
muzon knew he was beat and so made his
body burst open with incredible force
yorichi was so skilled and fast that out
of the 1 800 he got more than one
thousand five hundred pieces but the
remaining pieces were enough for muzon
to eventually regenerate and then he
spent the rest of his life hiding and
running from yurichi until yorichi died
of old age so understandably when he saw
the earrings again on tanjiro he wanted
tundra dead yurichi passed on the
earrings and sun breathing through a
dance of the fire god to sumiyoshi and
his descendants until he got to tanjiru
now tundra was not immediately as
talented as yorichi and his youth so
he's not the chosen one in the sense
that he's naturally the most talented
person ever but he is the chosen one in
the sense that with enough training and
help he was the one able to finally
finish off muzon using sun breathing
something that even yurichi didn't
succeed in doing tundra's chosen one
potential is made clear throughout the
series and he is consistently getting
stronger in accomplishing more and more
impressive feats he helps hashtag and
uzui beat upper moon 6 gyutaro after his
demonstrator mark evolves to look even
more like yorichi's proving once and for
all that it's not just a scar with this
evolved mark he actually manages to cut
the upper moon's neck something hasha
tangen couldn't even do when hashira
iguro shows up telling tengen not to
retire tengen says someone has grown
strong enough to help replace him
meaning tanjiro so even at this point
you could make the argument that tundra
deserves to be considered hashira level
especially with the dwindling number of
hashira and what's more tundra only gets
stronger from here with each fight he
starts to look more and more like
yorichi in one way or another against
kyotaro his scar temporarily changed to
look more like urichi's against upper
moon 4 he uses yorichi's own 300 year
old blade and turns it red when
delivering the final blow during the
tanjiro and giu vs akaza fight his
demonstrator mark extends again and he
gains access to the transparent world
another ability that odichi had in this
state he can easily avoid akka's final
form attack which even demon slayer mark
giu fails to do furthermore akaza
realizes tundra reached a selfless state
which is viewed as the domain of
supremacy for martial artists the thing
akasa has been aiming towards his whole
life this state is characterized by
insane speed for one but also eyes that
have no trace of hatred and anger no
malevolence or fighting spirit it very
much sounds like yorichi who was a stoic
dude who didn't carry around hate and
never had the fighting spirit and drive
to be number one he just did what he
felt was the right thing to do and what
he considered to be his duty and he just
ended up being the strongest ever after
this akasa admits tundra surpassed him
at least in that moment where he cut off
his head akuza kept going on for a while
he was about to regrow his entire head
and become like muzon a demon unkillable
through decapitation but his memories
and the spear of his fiancee made him
decide to let go and self-destruct
instead of regenerating even though some
might argue that tundra wasn't no shape
to battle anymore and akuza could have
wrecked him if he just decided to
regenerate in his own mind akisa
accepted defeat he thought to himself
that this fight is over he lost when
tundra cut off his head he suffered
total defeat even if it was temporary
tundra completely outclassed him and so
at this point tundra has not only
surpassed rengoku but demonstra mark
awakened giu as well at this point he's
already beyond hasha level and it's no
longer just his similarity to yorichi
that deserves fear but also his own
insane strength that he's shown a
hashira is supposed to be outclassed by
an upper moon that's how it was for over
a hundred years but here tundra
outclassed upper moon 3 truly a
horrifying level of power for a human
and you can see he's coming into his own
as the chosen one and successor of
yorichi's sun breathing style i also
think that his sword color going from
black to red also goes well with his
personal backstory since his family
worked with charcoal which starts out
black and then turns red when set on
fire or activated so to speak and the
fact that he has kyojura's flame-shaped
guard on his sword is perfect because
it's like that fiery will that ngoku
embodied and passed down is now lighting
up the charcoal that is the black blade
and turning it red then there's also
tanjo's red hair which is also similar
to urichi's all details that lend to the
idea that tundra is special and is
destined to be the last sun breather who
defeats muzon finishing what yorici the
first sun breather started so now let's
get to this final battle and see how
tundra becomes even more frightening to
demons and then to all non-demons as
well after all i did title this video
why everyone is scared of tundra for a
reason and not just why every demon is
scared of tanjiru during the final
battle where the demon slayers fight
moves on tundra fights the longest out
of anybody which makes sense for the guy
using the strongest breathing style and
the successor of muzon's arch nemesis
not to mention the fact that tundra is
the main protagonist of the series as
well after muzon starts infecting tundra
with his blood he tells everyone the
blood is a deadly poison that will cause
cell destruction and death he even
proclaims tundra as dead at one point
but as if to make tundra appear even
scarier he returns from the dead aka
manages to survive despite half of his
face being infected by muzon's blood he
does not look pretty here and even muzon
says at this point that tendril looks
awful that it's hard to tell which one
of them is the demon and that tundra is
making muzon's skin crawl rather than
the other way around this is another
point in which muzon can't help but
think of yurichi when confronting
tangirum it's at this point that tundra
realizes the 13th form is combining all
12 forms of sun breathing and performing
them over and over again with increased
speed and accuracy and he actually
fights muzon one on one and survives for
a while true muzon says tundras no
yorichi but tendril has not only
yorichi's teachings passed down to him
including ones designed specifically for
defeating muzon but also he has helped
that urichi didn't have like tamayo's
poisoning of muzon all the hashira and
other demon stares coming in and
assisting tendril when necessary not to
mention all of the damage yurichi did
during that battle centuries ago was
burnt into muzon on a cellular level
they appear on his body when he's
drained enough from the fighting and
poison and these scars reveal muzon's
weak spots to further help tanjon the
others tundra may be the star of this
fight but this truly is a team effort
iguro is the first to regain
consciousness and step in to help tundra
after muzon wrecked all the hashra in a
previous attack together they actually
scare muzon enough for him to start
running for his life and then they have
to stop him from escaping muzon even
tries to divide but he can't because
tamayo's poison is preventing a super
handy divide and explode attack he used
against yurichi with a lot of help
tanjiro eventually ends up pinning muzon
to a wall as the sun is rising as the
sun comes up muzon turns into a giant
baby literally he tries to crawl away
but our side keeps attacking until he
eventually dissolves in the sun like any
other demon so already we discussed why
demons are scared of tundra at first he
reminded them of yurichi who traumatized
muzon then he actually became strong
enough to justify that fear and
eventually even muzon was trying to run
away from him not only did he outclass
upper moon 3 he played the biggest role
in defeating the demon king himself and
became the strongest living demon slayer
surpassing the hashira we then find out
that as a goodbye present mouza
entrusted his feelings or will to
tanjiro although tundra was partly dead
when muzon turned into a giant baby
since his breath and heart had stopped
he wasn't all dead muzon noticed that
not all his cells had died so muzon
poured all his blood and power into
tanjiro in the hope that he will become
the strongest demon the king of the
demons and the one that will conquer the
sunlight and theoretically if demon
nezuko was able to do it it makes sense
that tanjiro a close relative would be
able to do it as well so muzon just
created a demon even stronger than
himself the most dangerous being that
the world ever had to encounter up to
this point crazy to think it would end
up being our protagonist muzon also
mentions the fact that tundra knew the
same breathing as that monster to use
his own words meaning yorichi we saw how
strong kokushibo was with moon breathing
so imagine how strong tangera who got
all of muzon's blood and power and knew
the strongest breath and could have sun
immunity would be he'd be unkillable
since he'd be able to regrow his head
like muzon and survive the sun like
nezuko he could just keep getting
stronger and stronger however this
remains more of a possibility than a
reality since tundra isn't a demon for
long i do believe that if he remained a
demon he could have used enhanced sun
breathing eventually like kokoshibo used
demon enhanced moon breathing but demon
tanjiro is initially more like a wild
animal than a tame and skilled swordsman
it's crazy to see demon tundra in action
muzon was right that the sun doesn't
kill him he is able to become a kind of
bony demon dog awk with bony whips
coming from his back they also noticed
that along with sunlight the red blades
have no special effect against him
either he then launches an attack from
his mouth reminiscent of an energy ball
or biju ball from naruto it's a
devastating attack but we don't even get
to see its full potential because nesco
interferes by blocking it with her arm
giu notices that tundra held back since
he's not killing the bleeding prey aka
nezuko right in front of him thus there
is still tundra in there keeping this
demon from throwing everything it's got
at nezuko and the rest in the end they
have no chance of physically
overpowering demon king tanjuro and have
to use medicine and friendship to reach
him so despite muzon telling him he is
the perfect demon and the ultimate
living creature tundra decides he'd
rather die as a human than live forever
as a demon and reverts back to normal
now without the use of the eye and arm
he lost during the battle and that
brings us to the happy ending where
tundra retires into a peaceful simple
and honest non-demon slaying life with
kano and the others he was feared as a
demon slayer for being the last known
sun breather for being urichi's
successor and then for being the
strongest living demon slayer then he
briefly turned into the strongest demon
ever the ultimate living creature as
musang called him that would be
unkillable and could potentially use
enhanced sun breathing down the line
even yurichi would not have been able to
kill the final form of demon king tundra
because he was unaffected by red blades
and sunlight he was the biggest threat
the world had ever seen but luckily the
medicine tundra's friends and family and
his own will to do what is right turned
him back into a human so yeah tundra is
well beyond hasha level beyond upper
moon level and even beyond muzon level
when he becomes the next demon king he
was feared by all demons as a demon
slayer and then by everyone else when he
became a demon but that is it for this
video let me know in the comments what
you think demon king tundra could have
looked like down the line if he accepted
being a demon and maybe even used sun
breathing in demon form like hokushibo
used moon breathing what do you think
would have happened if yurichi faced
this final version of demon king tanjiro
those are some very interesting
questions from my perspective and i'd
love to hear what you guys think about
them if you did enjoy this video and
want to keep the demonstrator videos
coming you know what to do challenge
within and smash that like button with
no mercy remember smashing that like
button
energy and passing is muzon energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future demonstrator videos and updates
and while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing demonstrator playlist that
includes videos on all the hashira all
the demon moons and much more videos
just like this one link to that is in
the description and until next time see
ya space cowboys
[Music]
you